well basically what it is is when you
have the log of the same base your log
base B equals log base B these bases are
the same these logs are equal to one
another which means that the arguments
okay this quantity here is equal to this
quantity here so a lot of base B of x
equals log base B of Y then X must equal
Y it's very similar to what we did when
we talked about the one-to-one property
for exponents if you have 2 to the x
equals 2 cubed you can see these bases
are the same so X must equal 3 right
it's very similar for the one-to-one
property for logs now let's get into
some examples we're gonna start easy and
get more challenging so log base 3 of 2
to the X to X minus 5 equals log base 3
of 21 you can see they're both log base
3 that's important and so that means
that this argument must equal this
argument so we have 2x minus 5 equals 21
add 5 to both sides right so we get 2x
equals 26 divided by 2 and you can see
that x equals 13 okay let's look at a
little more challenging example now
these are natural logs and what we're
going to do is we're gonna use the
properties of logs to combine these
together into one log and the way you do
that is when you're subtracting you can
write this as one log by dividing the
arguments it's the log of X my minus the
log of 2 natural log of X minus natural
log of 2 you take this quantity divided
by this quantity so natural log of X
divided by 2 equals the natural log of
10 and you can see now we have the same
base natural log is log base E so that
means that this argument is equal to
this argument so X divided by 2 equals
10 we can multiply both sides by 2
and you can see that x equals 20